how do you describe what you do for work
when you meet someone at a cocktail
party I like to say that I help people
go where you're treated best those are
five magic words I learned them from my
father at a very young age he gave me a
permission slip I did not have to stick
around where I'm from um I didn't have
to stick around and take care of my
parents because they didn't want their
kids taking care of them they wanted
their kids to go where the best
opportunities were and he thought back
in the 19 1990s where I grew up in the
United States that there would be better
opportunities by the time I got around
to being in business and so what I've
discovered is if you live in the United
States or if you live in a country like
it you're probably paying way too much
in tax I'm not saying you should pay
zero but you're probably paying too much
for what you're getting um there's
probably some things holding you back uh
I think what we're seeing now is there's
a lot of opportunities in business
around the world and increasingly this
multipolarity where the US is pitted
against other places and so there's
going to be a choice which Market do you
want to sell to uh and so we help people
at NAD capitalist reduce taxes become
dual citizens find Opportunities around
the world that most people don't talk
about uh because I'm a pretty contrarian
guy and I think that what we think is
the best is often
not it's strange having read and listen
to a good bit of your work it's from
first principles it's kind of weird that
people presume well this is the place
that I was born so this is the place
that I'm supposed to work and live and
die and bank and pay taxes and date all
of these things yeah well uh you know I
was born in Cleveland Ohio in the US uh
right on the lake and right across the
lake from Canada and I look and I say
what if you know I'd been born right
across that Lake I mean the grand scheme
of things that lake is a pretty small
pretty small thing and if you're a
Canadian
uh you can leave your country and you
can leave your tax burden behind for one
thing you don't have to follow Canadian
regulations when you live overseas uh
you have a passport that for years I
mean it's it's the joke uh that people
respect you a lot more and people are
more open to giving you a bank account
in other countries just think like life
as a global citizen is a lot easier life
just as a Canadian traveling is a lot
easier um you know people aren't picking
on you and to say that you're born that
close to where your identity would have
been different to mean to me just shows
kind of the miracle of birth but not
only you know if you the movie Midnight
in Paris talked about you know were we
born in the wrong part of you know
Earth's history you know would you
rather been born 50 years ago you know
we can't change when we were born but we
can certainly change where we were born
and if we weren't born in a place that
we want um we can change that I also
happen to think as my father said sure
when I was born in 1984 the United
United States according to the St the
studies that do this it was the best
place to be born but there wasn't a lot
of competition I'm talking to you from
Malaysia I think it's the best value
destination in the world for someone who
can work from
anywhere and you would have never even
been talking about it in 1984 but you
can talk about it today and so there's a
lot more competition the world changes
the world evolves and even if you were
born in the right place maybe it's not
the right place
today what about cultural displacement I
was born in the UK and now live in
America on an 01 visa and I there's part
of me that that does feel culturally
displaced you know a lot of the um way
markers that you would references and
things from history and things from your
past and stuff from culture and Stu from
all the rest of it that that can be a
little bit disquieting what's that like
as a global
citizen well obviously different places
at different cultures I think that if
you look at it in a sense we're all the
same obviously we all the same
motivations um in a sense we're very
different there are places that I think
it is difficult to adapt um I think that
part of my background in the United
States coming from a very humble
background probably caused me at times
to spend a bit more time in places where
people were a bit less agreable um
because you're you're taught you know
where I'm from uh that you know look
inwardly
first uh but let's take Malaysia for
example I think you have probably some
of the kindest people in the world it's
a quality that I've looked at is being
extremely important um I look at a place
that I've spent more time in the last
year next to where you're from in
Ireland um some of the most polite and
kind people uh and welcoming people in
the world they've done an incredible job
you know transforming their country in
the last 30 or 40 years uh and I say to
myself I mean those are important
markers so I think the things that we're
used to uh sure there's places where I
go and I still have an American mindset
and it's frustrating and I was just you
know just talked to my team yesterday
with my people all over the place you
know we're going to run this like a
business run by a guy who's from the
United States and yet being out of the
United States for many many
years causes one to develop an
international mindset to where if I were
to go back to the US today I think I'd
feel very culturally displaced from
there because number one I'm politically
homeless I don't agree with Trump on
everything I certainly don't agree with
Biden on
everything um and yet if you don't agree
on everything it seems for a lot of
people you're a communist or you're a
fascist
um I think that people are at each
other's throats where I'm from I think
that would be the ult ultimate cultural
displacement that someone who's kind of
developed an international sense of um
of thought wouldn't be very welcome
there today how many passports and bank
accounts and stuff do you have I think
it's five passports now always looking
for a new I I I had a coach he said how
about we how about one new passport and
one new property a year the properties I
decided I I kind of got pitars around
the world because I like to split my
time up have employees in different
places kind of got tired of staying in
hotels but okay the passports I think
for now I'm good um yeah we've opened
probably dozens of bank accounts all
over the world we have multiple
companies around the world um we invest
and things like stocks all around the
world um and as I said I mean we're
really my business noad capitalist I
mean we're expanding uh to higher people
around the world we've largely been kind
of Europe focused over the years um but
we're really doing a lot of work now in
Latin America
um hopefully soon in Asia so I mean for
me they call it planting Flags I want to
have as many flags as possible uh but I
want them to be correspondent to what
the opportunity is I live in Malaysia
because as someone who can work from and
I live in Malaysia mostly the winters
now is someone who can work from
anywhere and who can live anywhere for
me the idea of paying $10 million for
this
apartment um and then paying five or $6
million in tax because Singapore can
demand that just as a one-time you know
purchase for a foreigner I don't have to
do that to live in a place that's
marginally easier uh to live in than
Malaysia where you know this place is
600 Grand and everybody Marvels at how
cheap that is for what you get uh and
yet if I want a bank I trust Malaysian
Banks but Singaporean Banks to me are
the gold standard so I'm looking for all
the places around the world where I can
take advantage of what are you the best
at and the reality when we say you know
go where you're treated best the place
where you're from they're probably not
the best at
anything um the US does not have the
best banks they of the safest Banks I
mean they have the most bank failures of
any country in the world combined um so
but if they are if they are the best at
something you should you should use it
for that um I'm looking for places that
are the best and I'm planting Flags
there and I think places all around the
world are the best at something how do
you conceptualize the different elements
that a person has to manage or play with
country of residence bank accounts tax
status stuff like that is there a a
series of knobs and levers that we're
playing
with yeah I think so I mean what what I
decided to do in our business was to
make it based on what I've experienced I
mean a lot of people out there will help
you get a passport in the Caribbean um
but I thought there's a real world
challenge of going out and doing this it
can be tough I mean you go to Banks a
lot of banks don't want to take
non-residents these days for example but
yeah I I broke it down and I'm
continuing to add things to this day I
mean you mentioned dating I think that's
a great one to add where should you be
dating um I just had a a guy who works
for me he lived in Ireland he broke up
with his girlfriend of seven years okay
obviously there's a bit of the rebound
phase going on but I took him to a
couple of our offices we had some work
to do around uh other parts of kind of
Eastern Europe and it was a dramatic
shock that like wow these people are
much more interested in me uh than maybe
someone back home where I'm just kind of
standard fair and I think that if you
just look at everything in life and
saying am I doing this the best people
probably ask themselves similar
questions just without the geographical
element so I decided to add this overlay
of geography to
it okay so tax is one that's important
how much tax you are paying uh ability
to invest bank accounts quality of life
what else am I missing from the big the
big buckets where's your company based
which I mean in part is based on where
you live right I mean so the the the
mistake is if you live in the United
States but you put your company in the
British Virgin Islands you can avoid tax
I mean they figure that one out right I
mean you have to to move as well but if
you live in a tax friendly place like a
Malaysia um you can have your company in
a number of places that serve you well
um where are you hiring people where do
people have the best attitudes um I
don't know that we're paying people that
much less than we'd pay them in the US
um they're certainly probably keeping
more money than they would to an
equivalent American but we can start off
paying them less to begin with and then
quickly scale them up once the risk is
risk is reduced we can hire more people
try more things um so I think for a
business owner those are important
elements where's your business based
where are the employees based and they
all work together but then again there's
the personal things where's your data
stored um you know if you're in crypto I
think people should perhaps have a
ledger and The Ledger should be stored
somewhere that's an asset Haven where's
your precious metals stored um you know
I I I I've always liked lightweight
business models my entire life I've
started my first business at 19 I never
wanted to have a business where I had to
buy a ton of assets I had to have a
factory I think it's a business because
then you could just be profitable
immediately and then you scale uh and
nobody owns you I think the same thing
about life if I want to live in Malaysia
do I really want to be you know dragged
down to all my stuff is stored in
Malaysia if I own certain Investments
it's all sitting in my living room I
want to run kind of a lightweight
lifestyle where I'm flexible um I think
that's the name of the game this in this
Century what's the difference can you
explain to me between owning a passport
being a citizen being a resident having
a Visa what what what do all of these
different things mean citizens so I mean
generally speaking citizens are entitled
to get a passport there's some things
where you know a stateless person can
apply for passport and then what's the
national but generally speaking if
you're a citizen you can apply for a
passport so a passport is a travel
Document you want to be a citizen um you
know I've been talking there's there's
kind of a the latest version of an old
scam the Mexican passport scam where
some guy puts your name in the system
and they can print at a passport but you
don't have any of the formal stuff that
shows you've actually been naturalized
and eventually at least historically
speaking people start traveling these
passports and they eventually have a
problem because you're not really a
citizen so you want to go through the
proper Channel to become a citizen and
therefore to get a passport um so
there's any number of ways to get a
passport you know if you have a a parent
or a grandparent or a great-grandparent
in many cases who comes from somewhere
you can potentially go back and get that
citizenship um you can go back you can
go back to a great grandparents
generation and knock on the door of the
embassy and say hey I fancy a
passport in some they even took it back
even further um like Italy for example
as long as Italy existed or Slovakia
they even went back one one further
recently yeah um you have to get your
documents obviously the further back the
harder it is to prove and there are some
exceptions like in the case of Italy if
somebody became American before you were
before the next one was born there was
no dual citizenship I mean there's some
caveats but yeah you can go back through
your family tree and you can track that
and you can get a citizenship that way
there's citizenships you can invest in
um about a dozen formal programs and a
number of informal programs where if
you're starting a business and hiring 20
people there's probably a country that
would like to give you citizens ship in
exchange for doing that if you want to
make a donation to a Caribbean country
they'll give you a passport in a matter
of months and then of course you can
just go and live in some country and
eventually become naturalized two or
three years in Argentina up to you know
30 years in San Marino in in Europe you
know or or something like that um and so
to be a resident gives you permission to
live somewhere a country like Malaysia
is never really going to give anybody
citizenship Asian countries it's not
really their thing citizenship is kind
of an ethnic thing but you can be a
resident and so I can have a residence
permit for a certain period of time as
long as I you know keep my nose clean as
long as I maintain whatever got me the
permit whether I'm married to a citizen
whether I invested whether I did you
know started a company I'm a resident if
you're a resident in a European country
you can you know if you go to the UK six
years you live there X number of days a
year eventually you can apply for
citizenship and so you know there's
different ways to look at this Ireland
for example if you live there for five
years you can apply for citizenship
arguably one of the best passports in
the world not only in the European Union
but also has access you can live and
work in the UK Everyone likes the Irish
um and yet you can live in Ireland for
those five years as a special tax status
that locals don't have but that
foreigners can Avail themselves of so
you could live in Ireland speak English
have all the services pay some tax but
not the full 52% people are paying on
their salaries and then get one of the
best passp reports in the world so
there's different ways to approach it
plenty of Americans now just want they
want a residence permit in Mexico or
Argentina or Malaysia is a place to go
and be welcomed they want a citizenship
just in case something happens uh they
want a citizenship because I think in
the future being an American will be bad
for Global business and I've seen that
myself um but some people want to move
so it's you know is this a plan B is it
a backup or is it like hey what I did I
don't want to live here any anymore how
do I move somewhere else how do I
navigate the world yeah how just how
badly does the US rank on your Global
list of places from a tax and financial
perspective and if we rank it on tax I
mean it is the one country that just
across the board taxes citizens no
matter where they live here's the
international view I'm a pretty
libertarian guy I believe in lower taxes
I don't know why you have to pay so much
tax in the US especially because you get
nothing even my father shares the same
view he likes to travel to Germany now
he likes to travel to Europe he's like
all right you know what at least here
they're getting
something you don't get anything in the
US
and even all that
said I know no one ever signed up to pay
high taxes but if you live there you
know the deal in the US you got to pay
the high taxes if you don't want to pay
them you should be allowed to leave but
the US is the one country that without
restriction taxes you no matter where
you live now if you're a business
business owner you can incorporate your
business somewhere offshore you can pay
yourself as an employee of that offshore
company and and legally not have social
security tax you can exempt a whole
bunch of money you can defer additional
money at a pretty low rate I'm not
saying you're going to move overseas and
pay the exact same taxes we help
Americans pay a lot lot less but you
still have to file you still have to
keep track of all the rules um that what
happened when I gave up my US
citizenship was I was suddenly able to
access a lot more of my company's
Capital our company's a cash flow
company we don't have to reinvest at all
for our growth I took some money out I
built the collection of piar up so now I
can travel around and live the lifestyle
that I talk about always having someone
comfortable to go I couldn't do that
I've got an apartment here in qualen
poor that's owned by a company nobody in
the jurisdiction of the company
understands it nobody in Malaysia
understands it it was done for one
reason it's the legal way for me to
acquire real estate as a US citizen
without paying a huge amount of of tax
and so there's all these restrictions
that Americans have again if you stay in
the US pay your taxes if you want to
vote if you think Trump's going to lower
your income tax rate 2% good luck but if
you leave you should be allowed to leave
and I think that Australia is tiptoeing
in the way that the us is going Canada
there's been people talking about it
there's this notion now that citizenship
is not as much a privilege as it is a
responsibility it's an obligation that
even if you don't drive on the roads
even if you don't send your kids to
schools why aren't you paying because
you're American you should pay for the
privilege well wait a I didn't choose to
be born here and again I was born 50
miles from Canada and so for me that's
what's pretty unfair and so in that
regard it must rank like the lowest of
all I mean my friend is from Norway and
if he just leaves the country and moves
to Dubai in the first three years uh he
has to pay a certain amount of tax but
after that three years he's done and if
he moves to any number of night
countries that they like he's done so
that's like a that's like a very very
small version of what the US does but
the US for as long as you are a US
citizen you have to pay and you know
what if I liked the us so much I'd be
willing to pay that low rate of tax but
for me the issue is I think it's
offensive that there's this idea that
since the Civil War just having that
citizenship means you should have to pay
if I live there I'll gladly pay that's
the deal I was fully compliant when I
lived there I didn't agree with the
rates but you follow the law I think
people should have the chance to leave
and I think anything else is kind of
like uh it's abuse isn't there wasn't
there one other country with that Global
Tax
thing yeah I was funny because I had an
employee of mine they said oh I have an
aitran Taxi Driver this eastern African
country next to Ethiopia I guess it
broke away from Ethiopia in the 90s I
think and they imposed a diaspora tax I
think it was
2% uh on anybody who's living overseas
and I think that they're like oh if you
want to renew your passport show us you
pay the tax it really wasn't enforced
because as you can imagine like the
United States has a lot more Global
power to influence Banks and set up IRS
offices and everything else than Eritrea
does um you know War torn kind of the
North Korea of Africa um and she's like
yeah the guy says he doesn't pay the the
DS for tax uh so yeah they do it um
again there's other countries that in
limited circumstances do it Australia is
kind of tiptoeing in I think you'll see
more countries doing a facto version of
it as in it's already kind of the fact
that if you're leaving a country like
Australia or like Canada maybe um and
you just kind of live a totally digital
Nomad lifestyle with no
base did you really leave maybe you
should still pay us
so it's getting worse which is why I
think having second path Sports is
important I'm not opposed to paying
listen I I I will spend some time in
Ireland and I will pay
something but I don't think I mean for
50% of your income you know it's easy to
make 40 Grand and to say hey I'm happy
to pay my my four grand no one's arguing
about that when you run a business that
makes a lot of money and the government
almost gets in your way more than uh
they're helping you and you realize well
wait a second over there they're doing
it with 5% tax wh why do you need 50 and
oh by the way have you been to Dubai
recently the roads are a heck of a lot
better than they are in Cleveland where
I'm from
where's this money
going so uh I think there's a certain
class of countries where they're
clamping down because they don't like
the competition that I'm talking about
they don't realize I can come to
Malaysia with a territorial tax system
my company can be based somewhere else
maybe I'll pay a little bit of tax on my
own personal salary but my company will
be entirely taxfree and I can take a
dividend and I can pay a couple of
percentage points of tax at the most and
I I support the comp the country I buy a
lot of stuff maybe I employ some people
and they're happy with
that Australia and the US and Canada
don't like that Malaysia does like
that what is the process of saying I
don't want to be an American anymore
what is
that you go to a US Embassy overseas
obviously all the embassies are overseas
hang on so you have to leave you can't
tell America in America that you don't
want to be American anymore no because
once you right because generally
speaking there's two appointments you go
in the first appointment they kind of
explain it to you are you sure you want
to do it okay and then generally it's
like come back it could be you know the
same day it could be a week from now it
could be six months from now in some
some countries depends on which Embassy
you're dealing with um but after that
second appointment you you leave your
passport and you walk out and you're
still in this kind of transitional
status the state department hasn't
approved it yet um which is generally
kind of just a deao process um but I
mean you're you're in the sense not an
American anymore so I mean you you can't
walk out back on the US so like but
they're going to deport you to where oh
of course wow yeah I didn't even I
didn't even think of that how funny so
there I mean if you didn't plan this
correctly you could have no
passport they generally like they'll ask
me and I will say the most professional
experience I've ever had with the US
government was my expatriation like I
would even say
kind uh with the people now not everyone
has that experience um but I did and
they're like hey we want to make sure
can you know do you want to show us you
have another passport just to make sure
we don't want you to be stateless there
is there are a couple people who've
chosen to be stateless and then they
have to go and like get some stateless
travel Document it's really confusing no
one's ever going to understand like
don't don't travel if you want to do
that you're gonna have a tough life but
yeah I mean theoretically I guess if the
embassy doesn't force you to uh not
every and not EMB not every Embassy is
going to force you to prove that you
have another passport um I remember
there's a story of a guy back when dual
citizenship was far less common I met
this guy who lives in vanatu he
renounced in the 70s because he wanted
to become a vanatu citizen to be on
equal footing for business and you could
not be duel so he had to give up the US
there's no US Embassy in vanatu so he
flew to Australia they took his passport
he's like well how do I leave Australia
now they're like well that's not our
problem and there was this whole
discussion of like well you can just
hang out for 90 days and we'll Deport
you and we'll we'll figure out where to
deport you to and then
benatu eventually he got like an
emergency passport or something and he
got sent back but wow um yeah I mean
there is a little bit of planning
required yeah Jesus what about exit taxs
when you left is the is there what is
that is there such a
thing so yeah there's the US has an exit
tax by the way a lot of countries I mean
this is one thing people pick on the
US I get why they do
it um because the idea is if you made a
whole bunch of money here you don't just
get to wipe the Slate clean and pretend
that money wasn't made while you were a
US citizen um much of my wealth now was
made when I was living overseas so we
can't argue it's those roads and bridges
that are doing it for me but um they
would say well you were still a US
citizen you still had our support um if
you have $2 million or more if you
earned what's the inflation adjusted
number for this year I don't know
probably if you if you if you paid like
800 and some thousand dollar in income
tax federally over the last 5 years if
that's what your income tax bill was for
the last five years or if your taxes
aren't in compliance which you can you
can bring them into compliance before
you expatriate um so if any of those
things are are applicable then you've
got to pay an exit tax for basically
they sell your assets on paper so we've
had clients who come to us where the
first time they come to us they have you
know 10 million their business is worth
$10
million and so if they leave you know
they started it for zero that's a $10
million gain whatever that is that's the
tax minus a small exemption they're like
well I can't afford that then they come
back two years later now it's worth 50
million they can't afford to renounce
yeah right because I mean they I have a
friend in uh in Canada who has a number
of businesses that have grown an awful
lot and he he literally isn't able to
pay the money to leave yeah like a
financial prisoner of his own financial
success yeah so I mean like Canada and
other countries have an exit tax when
you become a non-resident because their
their taxes is residential if you live
in Canada you pay tax on anything that
you earn anywhere in the world so like I
invest in Cambodia if I get a dividend
from Cambodia and I'm a resident of
Canada Canada will tax that dividend
minus whatever I paid in Cambodia
whatever so people think oh that's a
citizenship based tax no because you can
just simply leave you don't have to go
to the Embassy and give up your passport
you just have to demonstrate that you've
cut your ties and you've departed Canada
you can return to visit within limited
you know parameters but you're not
giving up your citizenship to leave
Canada so he has the same exit tax just
not the same requirement to give up his
passport which what makes it more
difficult the last year was the first
year that I was fully exclusively filed
in the US and it wasn't like the UK was
coming knocking on the door uh I mean
I'm glad I'm glad that I didn't have to
go through the forms that's the reason
that you have an accountant that
understands this stuff but it's
relatively simple it's like hey I didn't
spend 90 days in the United Kingdom
therefore
I I don't I I I don't got to pay the
United Kingdom any cash but that's not
the same as it is in
America in the UK there's different
different tests depending on what
connections you have it could be you
know under 46 could be under 91 but yeah
um the days test can be difficult
because I think people think like in
Australia and Canada if I spend under
183 no no no that's just one of the
tests is how long you spend there but
what are your connections what do you
have but yeah they they let you go the
UK is not one of the worst ones um and
and
so it is aggressive is anyone else more
aggressive than America I mean
California is probably the most
aggressive of all so if you live in the
US and you live in California you're
just I mean that's
unbelievable I mean listen you know what
frustrates me people say there's nowhere
to go because they live in a bubble they
watch their local TV news let's be
honest by the way is the propaganda in
the US really that much different than
the propaganda anywhere else it's you
know they're telling you what the
narrative they want you to hear
um you know
it's people live in the bubble and they
say well where am I going to go because
their thoughts of where they're going to
go is Canada or Italy or something like
that by the way Italy has a tax
incentive now I mean at least they
realized hey we got to bring some money
into this joint I mean if you can pay a
flat 100,000 euros a year and you can
make as much money as you want they also
have a 50 to 70% reduction for the first
five years on taxes so at least they've
done something to bring people in but
you know what bothers me is there's
nowhere to go even in a country like
Ireland pretty laidback like the
immigration office really laidback the
tax
office laidback compared to the US you
come here to Malaysia you come to a lot
of places it is not what it is in the US
and I'm not saying you shouldn't you
know
pay um I'm a big fan of following the
law and just going to where you agree
with the laws um you know why why try
and fight and change the laws and fight
against all your fellow citizens what
you wish existed already exists
somewhere just go there and just you'll
fit in um but the idea that there's
nowhere to go is nonsense um this the
the enforcement system just the div the
divisiveness but just the adversarial
relationship with the government again
speaking as a Libertarian not a huge fan
of a lot of
government it's much less adversarial in
some of these countries whether it's the
police immigration
tax these handful of Western countries
it is almost unique how adversarial they
are what should people do if they don't
want to renounce their American
citizenship but they do want to try and
dial their tax back well if I mean if
again if you're British if you're
Canadian if you're from anywhere else
you should just find another place to
live if you are American uh I didn't
renounce immediately I I I I remember my
father read um how the taxes work to me
he would come home and read articles
from The Wall Street Journal when I was
a teenager and I said wait a second if
you don't live here you don't have to
pay that's ridiculous he's like well it
says here you can renounce your
citizenship I'm like maybe I'll do at 13
I'm like maybe I'll do that because that
seems ridiculous that they trap you like
that but nevertheless I didn't move
overseas and immediately renounce I took
advantage of dramatically lowering the
taxes so if you're an investor you're at
a disadvantage so right now you know
bitcoin's up and I was telling everybody
move out of your high tax country when
Bitcoin was at 16 ,000 now it's at
45,000 uh because you would have saved
that whole $29,000 Delta in capital
gains tax as as an American Investment
is passive Puerto Rico is an option
that's pretty much your option if you
want to lower your taxes on passive
Investments but if you run a business
and a business defined as not a one man
or one woman show but a business with
some employees and it can function
without you you can incorporate that
business in some tax Haven I think if
you're an American it probably should be
as zero tax jurisdiction just so the two
systems don't fight too much what would
that be like what would be an
example um well the UAE not really
anymore that was the one people think
about is Dubai I mean they've really
come in I had a one of our wealthiest
clients of all time messag me the other
night I love the UAE but uh this new 9%
not a fan uh Hong Kong still has a
decent system I mean depending on the
business you know the British Virgin
Islands there's also multiple structures
I mean you're probably not going to be
running robust Payment Processing any of
this so maybe there could be a us
element to your business to do things
like credit cards but maybe the parent
company is going to move somewhere else
and so it depends like if the parent
company I mean many different things but
you know traditional tax Havens British
Virgin Islands I live man probably more
difficult than it should be Hong Kong
now um you know Panama is not as robust
but that's an option um Biz not so
robust um depends I mean here in
Malaysia laan is 3% but uh set up a
company in probably a zero tax
jurisdiction figure out kind of
structure depending on what your
business needs depending on how people
pay you uh take a salary from that
company if you're married and you both
work in the business both take a salary
obviously I'm not giving this is not
formal tax advice um but if you're
married potentially you can take out
close to about 250 grand um you can
avoid Social Security and Medicare tax
and then on the rest of it you're going
to pay some lower rate of tax and so
then the question is if you can use
things like tax treaties or tax credits
to pay that low rate of tax to some
other country and then take it again as
a credit against the US you know rather
than moving to a zero tax country do you
move to a country where you can pay 5%
tax in Europe for example and then you
use that as an offset against the us
because you were going to pay the US
anyway you might as well put some tax
into Europe and then live in Europe if
you want to and then work towards your
passport in five years so like these are
the kinds of things that go into it um
if you're going to be an American these
days you're going to have to pay
something if you make more than six
figures um and again you know what if
you like the country and you want the
option to go back and you're like hey
for 10 years let me pocket a boatload of
cash uh fine keep the US pay the US I'm
not opposed to paying some tax I'm just
a guy who didn't want to live in the US
didn't want to be American and so why
would you not want to be something and
pay for the privilege if you like being
it pay 10% pay 8% I mean that's not so
bad it's a lot better than what you're
paying now keep the American passport
you're not going to get as good a deal
as as is you would as a as a UK citizen
just being able to pay zero but such is
life um The Challenge though is again
that passive income comes are you going
to sell the business for $50 million in
the future because that's where they're
going to nail you and so that's the
issue where you might want to look at if
you're only concerned about tax planning
expatriation because if you can argue
that your business is only worth one
million today and you only have a
million dollars and other assets maybe
you're under that $2 million threshold
and you can leave with no exit tax at
all and then once the business grows you
know I mean I again tax was not really
my motivator for leaving it was the
frustration of I don't like the way the
country is being run and I don't really
feel like I want to be part of it anyway
so why not just just expatriate but I
will say from a financial point of view
the time when that happened was very
fortuitous my business is worth a lot
more money now if I wanted to sell it
I'm going to save a lot of millions of
dollars because I because I left when it
was worth not really that a lot what's
the reality of this Puerto Rico
hack well I mean you've actually got to
live
there um I think it probably
attra there's different criteria but
might just call it half a year maybe
let's call it a little bit more than
half the year I'm a more conservative
guy I mean and I've seen some of these
things people pitch like uh what was one
of the ones last year the multi- pension
plan that one got unraveled and they
have all these different schemes that
various advisers promote like oh it's so
easy you could just you know I'm not a
fan of the oh it's so easy because
eventually that stuff comes crashing
down let's say it's a little bit more
than half the time in Puerto Rico to
satisfy all the things I do think it
attracts the kind of person who's like
can I just get on a raft and Float back
to Miami no don't do that like no don't
do that um it's a place that is not that
efficient what's the quality of life
like I've never been I I I don't I I
I've been there only once um I I think
people say they tolerate it um and and
by the way by the way people say oh you
know it's like people move from
California to Florida in droves now and
and they don't think anything of that
people move from New York to Texas in
droves I would argue you'd save a lot
more in taxes and maybe you'd have a
closer cultural connection okay a lot of
people from New York are in Texas now
but you might have a closer cultural
connection to someone in
Ireland if you're from Boston if you're
from New York then moving to
Dallas um but for some reason moving to
Ireland or moving to Panama is scary
moving to Texas or even Puerto Rico is
not scary because it's in the US I don't
think a lot of the the local Puerto
Ricans uh necessarily like this uh the
system that they have going on there I
think you have some of the same issues
as if you move to a foreign country it's
not that efficient people tolerate it I
mean if you want to do something at the
bank just prepare to spend all day and
so I get it I mean if you want to be an
American or if you just like if you just
can't if you already have tons of money
but you plan on having tons more I get
that there's certain people who want to
go there for me the issue was uh I was I
was single at the time when I
expatriated um I didn't think I would
date an American and so do you know how
many people I've had where their their
best tax move is to move to Puerto Rico
but they've got a Mexican girlfriend
well is she gonna get a green card how
are you going to hang out with your
Mexican girlfriend right um so I mean
that's where the dating piece comes in
like dude I I'll I'll take the
Colombians I'll take the Russians like
the okay not not anymore but as I'm
married but um that for me was the
problem in Puerto Rico is you're kind of
limited to who you can who you can be
with what do you mean when you talk
about the global citizen sandwich and
the trifecta
strategy so the trifecta strategy is
um I'm I'm as I get older I'm more
focused on being in in one or two places
uh and then just kind of briefly
visiting the others for business or
checking out opportunities um but for a
long time I said I I can't decide I just
love it all I'm a legitimately very
curious person I'm fascinated by
absolutely everything and I would you
know say I'd go to Mexico I I gotta have
some Mexico I gotta have some Latin
America in my life and then I'd come to
Asia oh I love Asia this is great and
then I'd go to Europe okay I need some
of this okay the trifecta is you pick
three home bases you get either a
residence permit or a citizenship uh
theoretically maybe you could live
there's a tourist in some countries and
you basically have three home bases and
you split your time between them now you
can modify it but I mean the pure
Trifecta as I called it was four months
in one four months and another and four
months and a third so it might be you
know from December through March I'm
going to be in qualm poor where it's
warm then April May June July I'm going
to go somewhere in in Europe and then
you know the rest of the year I'm going
to be in Latin America okay and I want
to experience everything the world has
to offer there's different business
lessons you learn from being being in
different places there's different
cultures um I mean Asian culture is
substantially different in some ways to
what you might be used to in the UK and
in the US and so some people 12 months a
year they're going to burn out a lot of
people come to Asia they do the two-year
thing that's why they call them expats
it's not permanent they're not
immigrants right they don't plan on
staying I think if you spent four months
a year in Asia in the best months you
would love coming back um and so that
was the trifecta and it just so happens
that in the kind of countries that I
tend to like that can be very tax
friendly and in some cases it's just
like hey you didn't spend six months in
Colombia so you don't owe us any tax the
goal was not tax avoidance that was the
side effect and so I'm in the tax
business right people don't come to me
to talk about how they don't like their
mother or they want to dance salsa they
come because because they have a problem
paying too much tax and so I prescribed
it as I like it for the lifestyle you
might like it for the tax the global
citizen
sandwich is exactly why I'm in Malaysia
Malaysia is
kort I'm not saying it's the absolute
best place it is the Best Value Place in
the in the in the world to live nicest
people it's humid but otherwise good
weather tons of consumer conveniences I
went to a five-star hotel where we have
our Nomad capitals live event uh last
year
they have a beautiful gentleman's club
like a smoke like a cigar lounge got
four cocktails at happy hour served by a
guy in a white dinner jacket who knows
everybody who's successful in the
country and four cocktails cost me 23
bucks uh the most beautiful Ambiance you
wear a smoking jacket they come and they
can get a haircut I mean there's nowhere
better you obviously wouldn't pay that
in
Singapore but I I I do trust Singapore
more than if I have precious metals to
store or I want to put put $10 million
in a bank I'd rather do it there I do
think Malaysian banks are pretty darn
safe but I'm not putting my $10 million
they just don't have as many options
they don't have as many investment
options as many currencies it's harder
to get the money out so I'm going to
Singapore next door that's the top layer
of the bread that's like the creme de La
Creme the meaty part the meat in the
middle is where you live Malaysia and
then the other layer of bread is okay I
own a home in Malaysia the trade-off is
it's not really increasing in value
that's that's a amount of Supply it'll
take 10 or 15 years for me to see much
appreciation I live my investment is a
lifestyle
investment and so you know I'm the one
of the largest investors in a fund that
a friend of mine runs in Cambodia I
think Cambodia and real estate has some
of the highest promise for capital
appreciation in the next five to 10
years of any Market in Southeast Asia
and it's accessible and so I wouldn't
live in Cambodia I wouldn't Bank you
know $10 million in Cambodia I don't
think I need to live in Singapore so the
nice meaty part in the the middle is
where you spend your actual life living
and then the layers on top are the the
extremes of the asset protection and
then the more adventurous kind of
capital appreciation can't you buy you
can do that anywhere you can buy land in
Cambodia as a noncitizen non-resident is
that right no there's like four
countries in Asia Tha Thailand was was
promising to open it up and I think they
scrapped it um for for high investors
Malaysia Japan parts of Korea I forget
the other one uh but Malaysia is
actually the most open in Southeast Asia
you can own land so you can actually buy
land you can build a house I have a
friend who's doing that uh in Cambodia
you cannot but you can own condo
buildings now uh you know there's a
program you know if you uh if you donate
money to a charity endorsed by The King
The King will give you citizenship then
you can go out as a newly minted
Cambodian Citizen and buy what you want
but um you can also set up a Cambodian
company and and and you can do that so
you know what my friend did was he said
up the Cambodian company pulled
everybody together because it's not
really cost efficient to do it to buy
one apartment um but generally in Asia
you're not going to get citizenship and
outside of like Malaysia you're going to
buy a condomin condominium that's how it
works but they're very tax-friendly
places they're very laid-back very L
Fair people come to qualm Port they
think oh it's a Muslim
country and everyone who comes here the
most Progressive people I know they say
everyone told me we don't care
especially if you're not if you're not
Malay Muslim I mean if you're Malay
muslim okay they're going to they're
going to judge you a little bit even if
you're a Malaysian but you're not Muslim
you can wear the shortest shorts you can
wear the tiniest tops you can do what
you can drink you could do whatever you
want we don't judge you that like that's
between you and your God we don't judge
you so it's this very laidback place um
and I'm a big fan talking about Muslim
countries that are both Muslim and not
Dubai being British that is the uh
probably the most common after somewh
like a season in a Bea for the summer or
or magalu or zanti or somewhere like
that uh lot of people going to Dubai a
lot of my close friends uh going and
living out there there was a period some
of my friends have been going out for
literally 10 years there was a period a
while ago where did you have to get you
had to know an emirati or something and
and if you knew someone who is emirati
you could kind of get this extra
blessing and then there was this other
period for a brief
while maybe five years ago up until five
or four or five years ago where you had
to go and do like a Visa Run once every
quarter or something and now it's a
little bit easier and it it continues to
be doing that but what's the give me the
the thoughts on Dubai because from a a
British person's perspective it's the
it's Nomad capitalist encapsulated in a
single
country again I'm a bit of a contrarian
right I mean I and I think I almost like
qualm think it is the best value but I
almost like it in a sense because it's
not
Bangkok a lot of people go to Bangkok I
just kind of like to do my own thing um
so we had our company in Dubai for a
while and we decided to move
out um the banking I think is quite
difficult I'm the quality of private
banking
is it's not ready it's just not uh and I
just had that experience as recently as
two months ago um I've got to go and
figure out you know what what what where
you know what's happening with some
money that I sent them because the
quality of service in the banking system
not impressed um if you want to run a
business I think it's m it's really
designed to for people who want to live
there so our finance team is in tobli
Georgia um and every time we wanted to
do something they're like well just come
into the branch it's like the US they're
like well people live outside of the US
what are you talking about like people
live said of Dubai like we can't imagine
that like because people who live there
who work in Banks and stuff their dream
was to live in Dubai how how can you not
live in Dubai that's impossible it's not
really set up for remote operations so
um and now the free I mean and now
they're bringing in this 9% tax and
they're applying it more aggressively to
even the free zone companies than
explain the 9% tax I haven't heard of
this so well there's this Global minimum
tax that they brought in on big
companies so if you have hundreds of
millions of dollars in Revenue the world
got together and said we can't have you
moving all your profits to you know
Bermuda let's apply some Global Tax that
applies across the board not to
businesses like yours and mine well I
don't maybe you're making hundreds of
millions but not mine
um and so they basically said okay
everybody's got to raise their rates so
a country like Ireland for example said
okay we're 12 and a half if you meet the
threshold we'll bump it up to 15 but
what also happened was some of these
countries that wanted to kind of get
along were like
okay well we'll increase our tax rates
just on everybody um and the UAE did
that they said okay it's going to be 9%
if you run an onshore business but if
you're in the free zones which is where
a lot of people would set up you know
there's different free zones in in Dubai
and all over the country as long as
you're not working with other UAE you
know entities okay and it's you know
you're not going to pay it's still going
to be zero I said okay that's kind of
like Hong Kong if you're based in Hong
Kong you pay tax if you're offshore
there's no way you can exempt yourself
and not pay any tax okay fine Fair
enough well then they started creeping
in more and more and more into the free
zones to where now it's like most people
running a business are going to pay 9%
even like we looked at into can we just
keep our our trademarks there no you
have to do transfer pricing you've got
to move money into the UAE from your
other companies to pay for the value of
the trademarks that you're using and
then we're going to tax that at %. so
the UAE basically rolled out a 9% tax on
domestic companies and then it's kind of
been creeping into the companies that
don't have any connection to Du they
just said hey it's 0% tax what a nice
place to go I can get a bank account I
can get a residence permit I give the
UAE incredible credit for making the
residence process that you mentioned
incredibly easy it is one of the easiest
in the world and if you want to
personally live there they've said for
now it's going to be 0% tax on your
personal so if you would just have again
stock earnings or something well
actually stocks if you have dividends
could be a problem but if you just have
capital gains if you have you know
Bitcoin whatever fine but if you're
going to run a business that's based in
the I I don't think it's that ideal but
I give them
incredible uh respect for how they've
made immigration super easy and it just
proves the point if you run your country
to where you don't have a big social
welfare system you don't let people get
away with crimes why wouldn't you let
anyone who sets up a company anyone who
invests some money why wouldn't you let
them come and be a resident I mean
that's the way the US used to be and so
I see in that point like it's kind of
like the new American Dream anyone who
wants to make something think of
themselves come on in we're not going to
make it hard and they don't but I think
on the tax side um in an effort to Plate
uh the global Powers they got a little
bit more aggressive than they initially
thought and it's not the government's
fault that the banks are difficult but
I'm just I'm just I'm not impressed by
the Banks I mean we are talking about a
country that changed the
weekend only a couple of years ago and
just for people that people that don't
know the Dubai weekend used to be Friday
Saturday so your Friday night would have
been a Thursday night and you went back
to work on a Sunday morning and one day
one day everyone just woke up and the
government said hey guess what the
weekend is Saturday and Sunday now all
the British like yeah are you gonna kind
like I'm working on Sunday like what the
hell's that listen I and I think I mean
Saudi Arabia is kind of doing this now
as well I mean Bahrain was always one of
the more liberal ones um I mean I think
the whole Gulf with the UAE being the
kind of of the biggest standout has done
an incredible job at what I would call
let's go out and figure out basically go
where you're treated best hey who's
doing this the best okay let's let's
just Implement that okay what what do
they got going on okay that that makes
sense policy perspective yeah how
interesting it's it's right I mean you
you know what the bit here's how I can
assess whether a country is a failure
and and I know this because I I we have
people who work in some of these
countries and that's why it was more
affordable for us to go there oh don't
know that's not how we do it we do it
this way well maybe the results suck and
you should change how you do it but your
pride gets in the way I have a great
respect for the UAE and these other
countries I mean they have a pride for
their country but it's not the pride
doesn't get in the way of let's make the
right decisions yeah and they did an
incredible job on that uh how would you
say like philosophically non- monogamous
when it comes to the
procedures yes yes yes I I think yeah I
think monogamy in in the context of
choosing countries and policies and
things it makes a lot of
sense one of the things I've had in my
head as you've been talking through all
of this today is dear God how much
paperwork is associated with all of this
you're talking about I mean dude I had
to submit and I'm aware I tried to get
into a very difficult country to get
into but I had to submit a a three-inch
thick 700 page hard copy portfolio for
my 01 and I you know to get a social
security number and there's no license
equivalency test America has the worst
hey guess what America you can't drive
no one can drive in America right no one
everybody's a bad driver there's no
license equivalency between the UK and
the us so I need to retake my theory
test in order to be able to get a
driver's license in order to be able to
get a car but before I did that I had to
get a social security number and in
order to get a social security number I
had to show my I94 but your I94 is only
triggered if you've entered the country
through the Border within the last 3
months which meant that I had to leave
to go to the Bahamas to come back just
to trigger this arbitrary number so my
point being I've had to deal with lots
of paperwork and I essentially live in
two country I I'm invested in some form
or a stakeholder in two different
countries and you're this like big long
octopus with his tentacles wrapped
around many
countries like how does how would
anybody get even begin to get this
started without just drowning in tons of
Correspondence
well I I was at a bank not so long ago
um in Serbia and I think the banks are
safe there I think it's a nice kind of
diversification play but it was never a
place that want to put a lot of money
and so I went I said okay let me let me
get a new debit card just in case I need
it I'm never goingon to need it but just
in case I carry around like this many
debit cards um and I went to pick it up
and they're like oh do you have a Dena
card I'm like yeah I guess it expired so
they're required by law to give you this
card card that you can make payments in
Serbian Dinars like nobody uses it but
they're required for you to give you one
and they're like oh we've got to cut up
your debit card and you've got to come
back in a month and I'm like I'm I'm not
here I'm here like once or twice a year
I'm not coming back so you know what go
where you're treated best I'm just not
gonna have a debit card and I'll keep a
little little bit less money in that
account and um you know that's what it
is uh I'm probably going to sell some
land I own next door in Montenegro just
the thought of oh my God I got to build
a villa you know what someone's probably
built a villa somewhere else and I can
just buy it if I want to and you know
what maybe I should just rent a villa
for a while and just like put the money
to work um so I think that you've gotta
you know that's kind of the whole
thought process behind what we're doing
is like you don't have to go to the US
because yeah I had some properties that
I owned in the US and it was the most
laborious process now the US real estate
market does have more liquidity than
some other markets but where I own these
properties it wasn't that great
and I sold them and there were just so
many fees and so many things to do and
just like I I mean I think like the
grass was literally half an inch too
long and I got a thing in the mail like
violation and they're like they just
want you to pay a hundred bucks that
doesn't really exist in all the other
countries I just went through I I go
through end of the year I pay all the
bills for seven properties I have one of
the people on my finance team help me
and it's pretty pretty darn easy and I
have people who have helped me it's in
in many cases in many countries it's
more informal someone was your real
estate agent three years later if you
want their help with the air
conditioning that I I'll just go over
there and check it out um you pay him a
few bucks so I I found that yes there's
bureaucracy um I mean having if you grow
the business large enough you just build
an in-house team that specializes in it
we do an in-house but I mean the same
with the with Dubai it just became too
much to manage uh you know and we just
said you know what we're just going to
go back where we were um so it is go
where you're treated best and I think
that again the US is an ex that's an
extreme outlier um I I saw a statistic
not long ago that if you're getting a
Green Card interview for I forget if
it's like a sibling or what kind of
family member you're trying to come as
through family
reunification uh from certain countries
like India Mexico China you applied in
1998 that's when you filed that's when
you that's when you did all the
paperwork to get approved you're now
coming in to finalize the process in
2020 well was 2023 then um now whatever
you think about family reunification I
mean we do that for people all the time
you know someone gets a Portugal
residence permit then they add their
wife through family reification takes
you know a month or two or something um
there's something the US system is
broken and again even in Ireland just
got someone a a work permit the other
day so they can go and work there and
they can work for their own company and
it's kind of a tax efficient way for
them to to live in the
country uh it took like a month and a
half the person made a small mistake the
solicitor pointed it out oh my God I'm
so sorry said the government
officer that doesn't happen in the U I
mean the US is an outlier it's very uh
adversarial very cantankerous it really
is I I mean and you had the best sit
situation I mean going to a US Embassy
in and I've been there in Georgia for
example you know and it just watch the
Visa interviews there I mean British
like that's a nice touch no no I went to
Guatemala yeah I went to the the embassy
there because the wait time I was 88
days into a 90-day Esther about to go
over and if I had I would have been
immediately banned from the country for
God knows how many years so I was like
right well I'll leave go to oh God uh I
had the choice between El Salvador B in
Guatemala and I was like right well
let's go to Guatemala so I go to
Guatemala I'm able to get know Berlin
2024 this is
2022 it's taken ages because there's
this backlog from covid for people
getting a one application blah blah blah
London 2024 uh Guatemala next week I'm
like hey guess I'm going to Guatemala
right um so that was I guess that was a
little bit sort of nomad NAD I mean
you're still brtish I mean right so I
think you you kind of stand out as The
Shining you know it's like a finally
somebody I like um an ex colonist
yeah no I mean like yeah I think if
you're British or Irish I getting an L1
is is more straightforward um but no
it's
it's you know I people say oh you you
you hate the US I just don't think
they're best at anything I guess
prisoner
population uh per capita um they're not
they're not even best at obesity
anymore so I mean like I just want to go
where things are best and um I I would
if if people take nothing away from
this I I just I never felt good in the
US again for multiple different reasons
but like when I started traveling you
know the TSA they open up your stuff
they're yelling at I just like just so
many interactions with the government
are unpleasant that when you go to so
many other countries it it's you think
oh it must be the same it's it's not the
same it really isn't uh that's it's just
not the norm
let's say that there's someone who's
listening to this maybe two people one
of them is American and one of them
isn't and they're thinking Andrew made a
bit of sense there I I don't feel a
massive amount of affinity I feel like I
could do with a change uh but I don't
really know where to start and going to
somewhere to Simply Be a tourist like I
need to perhaps I need to work in some
regard where would you like you
mentioned that Dubai is is very simple
what are some of the other places that's
like on the um the new passport bro
starter kit who's what what's included
in that well so I mean my focus I I've
been an entrepreneur my entire life and
I realized you know as maybe 20 years
old I had a Vonage phone if anybody
remember is V like a VoIP phone and I
would I would basically you know cold
call people for my business I would call
businesses uh hey do you want to buy
some advertising and I I I realized
pretty early on why could I do this from
anywhere and eventually I started to do
as I was as I was traveling uh I
resisted the urge to move fully but I
there were some years I traveled more
than half the year and I'd be China and
nobody would even know I would literally
call my clients that you know they would
know the difference
um and you know I I think that's the
perspective I come from is you have
something that you can take with you so
first I would develop that um is it you
know I'm a I'm a cryptocurrency Trader
I'm a stock investor I have an online
business I'm a consultant yeah
freelancer whatever I can take with me
the cool thing about the US is there is
more flexibility again not tax advice
but there's more flexibility generally
speaking on keeping your US bank
accounts and so you know where if you
leave the UK or Canada they're more like
you should probably close that um I
would get that in line first now I think
you know qualm poor versus like New York
was like 25 cents on the dollar I mean I
just you know four cocktails 23 bucks
that's like what one cocktail in Las
Vegas or something um you don't have to
make as much but I would get to the
point where I can I can support myself
um I mean Dubai does have a lot of
networking
opportunities um depending on what you
do um I think I mean it depends on your
personality I think a place like in
Ireland where they speak English where
it's very open I would say the UK but
the UK has no way to move there uh we
had n farage at Nomad we well we had
Nigel farage at Nomad capitalist live a
couple years ago I told him like you got
rid of the investor visa
the startup Visa doesn't really work
even if even when it rarely does work
it's like you have to be the next
Facebook or you have to be investing in
the next Facebook like there's just no
way for a person with wealth or a
business to move to the UK generally
it's just really there's not a process
for that um you can get a job and move
to the UK you can get married and move
to the UK but like a guy like me cannot
easily move to the UK so to me that's
kind of a bull workk um you know I like
a place like an Ireland somebody else
might like a place like a Switzerland
that has maybe more established I don't
know what you want to call it I mean
Dubai obviously is a lot of very new
money what about Portugal I saw Portugal
were advertising for a while come and
live in Lisbon it's on GMT we'll give
you a Visa that's simple and so on is
that not simple to get to they are but
they got rid of the they got rid of the
tax programs they had a great tax
incentive um crypto brow right they were
looking to try and bring people in that
were trading crypto like okay for
crypto yeah I I I've I unfortunately
I've lost some confidence in Portugal um
not a bad place to live um for me you
know the places that I I've mentioned
today you know Malaysia and Ireland
people complain in both cases for
opposite reasons about the weather to me
the weather is the least important thing
if you can't handle some
humidity turn on the air conditioning
you know in Ireland and du it doesn't
rain that much um so I think that use
case for Portugal is like oh the weather
is so nice I I've never entirely
understood that one um so some of their
incentives have gone away uh I mean the
answer is there's something for
everybody um I mean I think Mexico is an
interesting place a lot of people G is
Mexico simple to be able to spend a a
three Monon six month I'm going to go
and do my graphic design from there well
so I'm a big fan of having a residence
permit especially now so Mexico
technically is like the UK you get 18
180 days Visa free but much like the UK
they're not doing it anymore hey when
are you leaving I'm just here for the
six months yeah we don't accept that get
get the hell out or I'll give you one
month and then you need to leave um if
you can get a Mexican residence which is
pretty easy I mean everything's easy
nothing is easy but it's the
qualifications are straightforward
enough you have a couple thousand in
income every month um you can get a
residence permit live there all you want
obviously if you know live there too
long there's a tax planning question but
yes I mean Mexico is a straightforward
Place Latin America is a place where if
you have income you can get a residence
permit Asia is generally a place where
you need to have wealth put some money
in our bank buy a property you know put
in six figures Latin America is the
place where if you're just starting out
um hey show us 800,000 1,200 $2,000 a
month in income for the last three six
months 12 months whatever here's your
residence permit you can live here all
you want so um I mean I think Colombia
is interesting people live in medine I'm
in boguta I think all of Mexico is
interesting I mean Mexico City in
particular for me but there's so many
cities I mean to pick Portugal is
interesting they got rid of the tax
incentive Italy has a very interesting
tax incentive people like that
um you know it just depends on what you
want I mean I I I think we popularize
the country of Georgia very tax friendly
not as affordable anymore with all
coming uh east of turkey south of Russia
okay in the Caucasus you so now you know
Georgia the culture like in in
Georgia uh decreasingly
conservative coming into land
um yeah I mean it's a very kind of
conservative respectful culture
laid-back so like Armenia next door they
were always the ones who you there
there's like 40,000 Armenians in Uruguay
I went there and I saw Armenian
restaurants Georgians were always more
like chill enjoy great food great wine
great Hospitality if you know a Georgian
you've got like a friend for life um so
in that regard it's nice the culture is
a little bit different
um you know I've enjoyed it but I also
see why some people could get could get
stuck up on that uh I mean there's just
so many and then there's southeast Asia
I mean Malaysia Thailand um but that's
those are a little bit more restricted
to wealth and presumably a little bit
more procedural you can get digital
Nomad visas Thailand has the Tha Elite
Visa you pay a fee every five years um
so there are more affordable ways to do
it if your goal is not permanent you can
also come to Malaysia for 90 days on a
tourist visa and I would guess if you
left for a couple weeks and came back uh
they' give you another 90 days if you're
a Westerner um you know if you're not a
Westerner it's 30 days and that becomes
harder to navigate but if you can make
$2,000 a month I think it is you can get
a dig digital Nomad Visa that may not
last forever but the question is you
know what's your level of commitment to
this for me when I left the US I said I
lied to myself I'm gonna do this for a
year I knew I wasn't coming back it was
just hey keep the house don't sell the
house um but I always knew was it it was
done I think for some people there's
nothing wrong with saying I'm going to
have a five-year Adventure I'm going to
learn how the world works I'm going to
pick up some new ideas I'm going to
learn hey they do it over here same as
we talked about in the UAE hey here's
how they do this over here if I added
that I bet that would make my business
better I'm gonna save some taxes for
five years I'm gonna bring that money
back and then just you know enjoy my
life I don't think you have to do that I
mean I've talked about you know having
kids I could have kids and live in
multiple places you can hire a tutor
there's any number of different things
you can do yeah what that's that's a
question let's say that somebody does
have kids what's what's a a solution
that you look at for your clients
presumably a shoor that you would need
to pay that would have to fly and be
prepared to move with
you well I mean some people just move to
one place they move and they put their
kids in International School we've got a
a a private client right now he's like I
want to move to Thailand and uh I'm
buying in the same complex as the school
and
um I mean that there's something to be
said for that um you could you know this
international schools a lot of places
you could homeschool in a lot of places
I mean some of the northern European
countries are pretty nasty on that but
most of the rest of the world is not um
but if you don't want to homeschool
yourself so I I know a family we' got a
guy who's speaking at at our live event
coming up uh this year named Joshua
sheets and he's a family of four and
they homeschool them and they travel
around and they do it themselves I also
met a very successful guy in the
entertainment business who is doing kind
of my Trifecta he's I heard you say
Trifecta and he's like that's kind of
what I'm doing he has the homes around
the world and uh they hired a tutor that
travels with them so there's different
ways to do it so but my my point is I
don't think that like this has to be a
single person's game or a couple's game
I think you can keep doing it if you
decide to do it for five years and to
get the experience and to save the money
um maybe you get an extra passport in
the process if you settle down in one
place I think that's fine too uh it's
always good to have more options have
more knowledge but the idea that you
have to give it up because now it's time
to settle down um I mean I I mean I I
talked to my friend I said bring your
son your son's like 17 come over and
visit me in Asia bring him for two weeks
take him out of school he'll learn more
hanging around in Asia for two weeks
than whatever they're teaching in The
Chicago School System okay I mean
believe me so I you know we have this
bias that whatever happens in our
country somehow works now we complain
about our country Biden has sold us down
the river Trump is turning us into a
fascist hell hole whatever right We
complain about it but somehow it's still
the best in the world and that's not
just Americans everyone says a lot of
people say
that and it's like well wait a second
again what's best about it is your
education system the best I who was it
the other day it wasn't Guatemala but it
was something similar is now outpacing
the US in like math literacy or some
[__] like not not not Korea or something
you've heard of but like you know it's
like El Salvador or something like
they're they're better
now so
I I have a a nonzero uh cohort of
friends who are around about my age
mid-30s and they thinking yeah I'm going
to you know kids kids are probably going
to come along at some point maybe they'
got a partner or maybe they're looking
or maybe they're engaged or married or
whatever and they're staring down the
barrel of the US education system with
trepidation thinking like I don't know
if I put a child in I don't know what's
going to come out the other side and you
know look at how many different people
are trying to innovate their way away
from this it's walor schools or it's
like um there's one here that's Run apog
Park that's run by Tim Kennedy and it's
like all of this stuff sounds great but
I like all of these things are largely
unproven now that may be better than
something that's proven to also be
completely crazy or useless but like do
I do I want my kid to learn how to
whittle a flute out of a [__] stick
like am I going to teach him how to H
hog the ground like so the US you're
totally correct like we have these
things education I had a friend I had a
friend who moved to Dubai and he had a
salary like a million dollar salary so
he was screwed as an American because if
you just have a salary you just get a
small exemption you pay on the rest but
he at least was still paying less than
when he lived in New York City and he
told me when I had three kids I had to
earn $400,000 pre- taxes into school
said imagine for 13 years you put
$400,000 into some fund for those kids
and you had them live in Dubai they'd
learn another language they'd learn
International they would do you know
something else you're telling me the
extra money and not being in New York
and being somewhere International
wouldn't be far better for them here's
what else I think about it one of the
concerns that some of our clients have
and some of my old friends in the US
have is not just the low quality of
Education in the US but oh they're
teaching you know there's this whole
social conversation they're teaching
woke they're teaching this they're
teaching that and people sometimes get
upset with me that I'm not so angry
about this and I say I'm not angry about
it because I don't even know what it is
really honestly people aren't talking
about that stuff where I live and I
don't have to be a part of it I think
that what makes people angry is
powerlessness and so we convince
ourselves to stay in the bubble based on
where we're born because that's the best
that's what we're told and we're fed the
propaganda but then we G this sense of
powerlessness because we don't like the
way things are being done and we get
angry about it we become miserable
because we don't think there's another
option I have plenty of options because
I've decided to have options and so
therefore I don't have to sit around
like I don't have to bother myself like
if I don't want to do something or if I
don't want my kids to learn something
whatever that may be that's we're not
going to do it there's a there's a
solution to that I don't have to feel
powerless and carry this anger around
with me and I certainly don't have to
think that I have to base my entire life
on one Poli ition getting elected and
they're going to solve all my
problems I'd heard I think I've even
heard you speak about some people that
have traveled abroad when the wife is
pregnant to give birth in another
country how common is that as a nomadic
strategy well I mean I think it's much
more common for uh people to come to the
US and Canada and do that because you
know most countries in the Americas have
this Birthright citiz ship if you're
born on the soil you're given
citizenship uh I actually know somebody
from Armenia I did not encourage them to
do this I wasn't even aware of it they
got a US Visa she and her husband she
came over and gave birth now she has an
American child um that child cannot
sponsor her I was going to say does that
work upward for the
parents I think the child has to be an
adult and then they can bring you uh and
so that's a faster one that's I I don't
think you're waiting 25 years for that
one but you might wait five years
something like that yeah well you get to
wait the 18 right but the child always
has the opportunities um they also have
now this lifetime citizenship so it's
like really this person is watches my
stuff and they they didn't think of that
but the reverse I mean so this um the
the you know Joshua sheets they gave
birth to one of their children in Costa
Rica and so now they all got residence
permits in Costa Rica and the child's a
Costa Rican citizen um I think that's
great because especially if you're like
an American Costa Rica is a nice
antidote who hates the Costa Ricans
imagine you want to travel okay Costa
Ricans need a visa to go to the US well
if you're a US citizen you're going to
go with your US pass you're required to
um Costa Ricans can pretty much go to
most of the rest of the world you know
Canada Australia they can't go those are
kind of the the toughest ones but they
can go to the UK they can go to all of
Europe I mean Costa Ricans are pretty
well accepted all around the world so
are Al salvad so are Guatemalans I mean
those are pretty good passports actually
you wouldn't think that the people you
see you the entire story of that region
is not so much Costa Rica people are all
trying to come to the US for more wealth
but if you have wealth you have plenty
of options in Central America and so um
I think it's an increasing strategy
Brazil is one people go to Mexico is one
um sometimes you can get citizenship
faster in Brazil it's one year if you've
got a child or a spouse now you've got
to wait like an extra year to be
processed you probably should live there
for a part of that two years but um it's
in some cases a for you to get a
residence or even citizenship in the
country but if nothing else you're just
giving your child an extra and I mean
when I when I met my wife this is one of
the things it's like would you be
willing to go go to Brazil all right
that sounds reasonable I'm like that
seems like a pretty open-minded person
um you know again I I I had a friend who
told me you know what you know what your
superpower is is you don't have this
Nostalgia about things that cause you to
put up barriers oh we used to all go to
the Portilla for you know after high
school like you don't you don't get into
that and so my question is it's very
entrepreneurial I think I want to give
birth I want to have you know my mother
of my child give birth in Brazil for
example uh what do I need to solve for I
need to buy a few flight tickets so that
you know family members can come because
that's what people want okay we want our
family there um I need to you know maybe
you've got to go there X number of
months early for certain kind of you
know appointments throughout the
pregnancy you know like that's what you
have to solve for and the payoff is you
now have a child who has a passport that
potentially there's a domestic economy I
think Mexico is is I mean look at the
peso it's done incredibly I was on CBS a
couple weeks ago talking about the pay
it's incredible against the US dollar
Mexico is moving in the right direction
I think you're you're potentially giving
them a passport in some of those
countries there's going to be a lot of
opportunities if nothing else it gives
them an opportunity to travel gives them
more places to live I mean just you're
just giving them a whole world of
opportunities you mentioned there about
living in a place before you perhaps
move there in your experience are there
any locations that are fun to go on
holiday and might seem romantic or
seductive as an idea but the reality of
living there for one reason or another
is not what the holiday
promised I was thinking the other day
about Vienna uh because I love Vienna
and and um now Austria has no tax
program again my goal is I my goal is
people confuse this I'm happy to pay
some level of tax we can argue whether
tax is fair or not fair my goal is not
to always pay zero if it happens that I
pay zero great if I pay a little bit
great I don't think any country is worth
if you're a successful person 40 or 50%
oh you get free health care well that's
great you made 10 million you paid 5
million you could have bought your own
Healthcare
um but I think that the challenge of
some of those places that people like I
mean my father loves
Germany um he just likes the vibe um
it's harder to meet friends there I
really look at
optimizing um closed I mean I remember
flying back from Vienna 14 years ago I
sat next to a guy American guy married
to an Austrian woman he said it's just
it's just a harder place to make friends
now I think once you make friends in
some of those places it's they're better
friends than you'd have like an LA I
mean it's more serious friends but I
would say the same thing about Georgia
for example I mean I have always been
helped whenever I need something and it
didn't take me that long to integrate
they're just open people so listen I'm
not saying this is good or bad I love
Austria um but I think that you know
maybe some of those central European
places that a certain kind of person
like myself who doesn't like the
southern European laid-back Beach Vibe
they think oh Austria I love Vienna but
I think you're GNA have a harder time
making friends in a place like that and
no I don't think it's the language
barrier uh I can get by in Spanish my
Spanish isn't fluent enough and I'm
certainly not fast enough to to engage
in the long conversations that the
Barista in bulata wants to have with me
if I solved for that I could have tons
of friends in in
Bogata um so that's that's an issue the
language barrier I don't think in in
Central Europe it is
um you know I think there's places in
Eastern Europe that are very direct I
appreciate certain directness over time
the directness turns into brusk in some
cases um obviously and I'm just I'm not
a big fan of Resort destinations I me I
I think people should you
know I don't understand the thing of
living in a vacation like living on a
Caribbean Island but to each their own
somebody might like that uh I'm not a
laid-back person but I think that you
want to optimize for where can I make
friends easily and some of the happiest
people that I know who are expats or
even immigrants in very far-flung
cultures none of them their friends are
expats I've got a friend who lives in
Thailand all of his friends are Thai and
they're educated they speak English He
Speaks some Thai but they kind of
accommodated him in English but he
thinks like a Thai person with some
American attributes but he really kind
of has the whole kind of Thai approach
um and he's stuck with it for that
reason so I think that you you want to
maybe have some local friends and if you
have a hard time doing that I think
that's probably a place that's more
difficult how many of the clients that
you're working with and the people that
you come into contact with are doing The
Nomad
thing as a protection strategy kind of
like being a a I guess a global prepper
in some regard um how how is that is
that on the rise what are you noticing
with Trends with regards to that it's an
increasing number I mean there's always
waves right so I think we're going to
see that again this year with Bitcoin
and cryptocurrency as those go up um
it's just as we saw in 2021 Co I think
was a big wakeup call for
people um and we can debate you know I'm
sure there are some people who have
views that are more extreme than mine
but I mean governments around the world
were pretty restrictive and it showed
that citizenship really is an obligation
I if you were Australian you couldn't
leave and you couldn't return and look
at how many people in Australia said
well yeah it's your fault you took a
holiday to
maius like what about the rest of us
like this whole kind of greater good the
individualism of you're a citizen you've
got a right to return to your own
country that's literally like
international law like the United
Nations this is not like some right-wing
concept um was just thrown out the
window and so I think people realized in
what people thought were these great
infallible countries like oh my country
can screw me um they don't really care
about me I've been paying all these
years and maybe I haven't even
complained compl about paying and now
when I need support I'm hung out to dry
and so I think you're seeing more people
saying yeah I want to backup plan um
whether that's about you know people
want Health Freedom we have people uh
from the US that when roie Wade was
overturned they said I don't want to
live in a country where abortion is not
legal what people don't understand about
me and my brand I don't judge I mean to
me that's that's the
international political views that I've
kind of picked up the the Dubai approach
of let's just have the best like what
works if you want to live in a country
where there's legal abortion I'm not
going to judge you for that um if you
want to live in a place where there's
less of a vaccine mandate I'm not going
to judge you for that um I might agree
with some of those positions and I might
agree in part or I might not agree at
all but like I think people are
realizing that again like where they're
born doesn't mean it's always going to
align with their values I I think a lot
of these countries are changing and so
yes more people are looking for a plan
B there's a fine line between kind
of forcing people to do what you've done
which they may not be comfortable with
and trying to open their mind to the
idea that you can leave uh again I'll
tell you what we get a lot uh I want to
leave in five years when the kids all
graduate I mean could the kids not go to
school somewhere else would that maybe
not be better for them I don't have kids
in high school so it's not for me to
judge I I think more people should have
a plan a not just because they can save
money on taxes but because I think you
learn a lot I think it changes you in
very positive Ways to Live other places
and I think that people don't move
because of this sense of fear again
they're happy to move to Florida not
happy to move an equal distance to some
other
country um but a lot of people want Plan
B citizenship residence sometimes they
want Plan B CDE
um so yeah not everyone that we work
with now is moving whereas when we
started it was I want to move I'm tired
of paying tax now there's a lot of I
don't want to move or I'll move later or
maybe I'll you know get a residence
permit and spend three months there in
the winter uh one of the guys I talked
to very kind of a wealthy guy didn't
realize as an American he just can't go
to Italy and spend four
months like yeah you can't it's 90 days
out every 180 you need to get a
residence permit you need to get some
kind of citizenship so it's kind of
clearing up some of those basic
misconceptions as well um but what is
the you men you mentioned it a couple of
times today that Italian whatever the
tax uh implications are and the what is
that they've got a couple
programs uh so Greece rolled one out
Italy rolled one out they're kind of
based on the Switzerland model it's a
lump sum so if you if you have a high
income uh you pay $100,000 a year if
you're married it's 12
and that's all you pay and that's more
flexible than like what Portugal system
was like where if you want to have your
company in a tax Haven and pay zero you
can do that you live in Italy whatever
amount of time per year and then you pay
them this this lump sum um so that's
kind of based on the the the Swiss
system with different cantons you can
kind of negotiate different rates but
it's it's cheaper than Switzerland um
and and you can get citizenship in Italy
uh maybe in Greece so that's kind of a
flat amount so if you make a million I
dollar a year or a million euros a year
that's you know it's 10% basically um
they also have in Italy uh incentives
and they're going to shorten it this
year for how long you can do it they're
going to take away some of the most
aggressive incentives but you can reduce
your tax rate like as a freelancer
between 50 and 70% wherever depending on
where you want to live in the country so
like in the in the north it'd be like
50% reduction so if the tax rate is 50%
you pay 25 if you want to live in the
south I think it's going to go down to
70% so if the tax rate's 50 you pay say
15 um so it's not zero but if you want
lifestyle I mean that's a much you know
better
deal one of the things I've been
thinking today is you travel around the
world you have businesses in various
locations bank accounts in various
locations and you mentioned about being
able to use different
currencies if someone put a gun to your
head and said you have to have all of
your life savings into one currency that
isn't the US dollar all right what would
it
be I'm glad it doesn't happen certain
there people who say I'm not threatening
you I promise I'm not threatening
you uh yeah be careful on the US you
gota you know they're they're pretty
aggressive over there I you know I
here's my construct there's judgmental
and there's
non-judgmental um and so I think
Singapore is a pretty non-judgmental
country I.E if you go there on like an
African passport they look at the list
is your passport in the list okay there
okay here you go 90 days welcome whereas
if you do that in the UK it's like yeah
you got a Visa but like you know I think
if you're going to hold a currency that
policy applies equally uh one of the
wealthiest clients we've ever worked
with says I you know I'm from a place
that like the West doesn't like I'm
against my country but I'm from a play
like the country the West doesn't like I
don't trust the UK I don't want my money
in UK Banks I wouldn't want to live in
the UK
and it's a it's just I mean for better
or worse there's a judgment of like we
like these people not like these people
I would probably say the Singapore
dollar it's based around a basket of
different
currencies um it's the freest economy in
the
world um they do a great job running it
I mean name a place where retail banks
are lending money to the central
bank
um I would say the Singapore dollar what
about you so let's say you're going
around to smaller banks in these
emerging or Frontier countries or
whatever can you actually put a
significant amount of money deposited
into the bank accounts there I you can
do whatever you want uh should you is
the question
um okay so that first that question and
then also how do you assess Bank risk
what's a good way to assess Bank risk
well I mean look at the bank failures in
the US last year there are more bank
failures in the US than I think pretty
much every other country
combined um so I Ian I think the risk is
in the US now you have the FDIC which is
basically broke has less than 1% of all
the money I mean if if you had a couple
big bank failures they're wiped out and
so you're basically dependent on is the
US Congress going to bail out
Banks uh I'm not so convinced that you
know oh I've got millions of dollars in
my bank account does the US Congress
really want to be bailing out with
taxpayer dollars in an increasingly kind
of populist country people who had
millions of dollars in the bank I'm not
sure if it comes to that they're going
to so I mean I look at banks in places
like Singapore there are some of the
highest rated in the world um that's not
an emerging economy but some of those
Banks might have operations in other
countries I mean you look at a country
we mentioned Cambodia there are stable
Asian banks that opened up offices in
Cambodia people are going and investing
in Cambodia they're building my friend's
strategy is he's buying real estate on
Corners in the city Center that one day
will get torn down to build skyscrapers
or shopping malls because they're doing
it I mean when I first went to Cambodia
they had like one
skyscraper now they're they're going up
everywhere it's like a front running
gentrification from that's it's a good
uh it's like a band name or a book name
or
something um
so like yeah am I going to get go to
Cambodia invest in like you know some
local bank I mean no I'm not going to
put as much money there uh am I going to
go to Armenia and invest in the bank
that's like owned by a guy I mean
there's like in Serbia me there are some
banks like the 18th lar just bank is
like it's owned by like a guy uh no but
I can go to Armenia and there's Banks
like there's there's French
banks um yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna feel comfortable doing that
because like do you think if that French
Bank in Armenia collapses that nobody in
France is going to pull their money from
that bank of course they are so they
have to make sure they move the money
around so
I I mean I think the risk is based on um
the the quality of the institution I
mean in Georgia the two largest banks
are traded on the London Stock Exchange
doesn't mean they can't go under just
like banks in the US were on the US new
US Stock Exchange they went under but I
think that if you look at those
factors um you can find decent Banks you
know in a country like Ecuador um it's a
lot of credit unions very high interest
rates um the US dollar is the official
currency which I actually kind of like
because if anything ever happens like
they're not going to like force you to
take their currency but you know the
banks are are there's no big huge banks
that you would trust like all your life
savings um I I think for me the point is
I wouldn't trust anyone with my life
savings I mean think about it
um and look at Nigel farage in the UK
whether you like him or not he you know
what we just don't want your business
anymore I mean that can happen anywhere
um so I mean I've had things happen to
me where they're like you know what who
oh you're charging for the like yeah
you're not really the kind of client we
want um and then what do you do like the
same Bankers that want you to like oh
give us all your business are the same
ones that would cut you off at the knee
so I don't care how stable the bank is I
don't want any bank to have all my money
um I just don't but you know for me yeah
I might put you if you put a million
dollars in Singapore would you put
$100,000 in the Bank of Georgia um
obviously you know in some of those
emerging World Banks if you're willing
to take on other currencies assing that
George and lry has done incredibly well
in the last couple years meanwhile you
made 133% interest so if you don't have
any better places to park your money
that's an interesting kind of
diversification there's some countries
if you do that you can get a residence
permit for example so it's like how does
this how does this stuff all work
together I wouldn't move $200,000 to a
Dominican Republic Bank but if you told
me oh we'll give you a fast track to
citizenship I I'd be I'm interested in
that right so um I think it all comes
down to what are you getting out of the
deal
um higher interest rates residence
citizenship um or just in the case of
like you know in a
Cambodia it's probably safer than you
think I'll give you one more thing
there's banks in places like the Bahamas
they don't even keep your money they
just have Accounts at bigger Banks all
around the world that would never take
you as a client you know B&B paraba in
France or Qatar National Bank Qatar oh
God the the StubHub ticket reseller of
bank accounts there basically just yeah
I mean they're small Banks they take
your deposits and they just have your
money somewhere they don't make loans
right I mean like why is it like the US
Banks get in so much trouble I mean they
just lend out to the hilt uh and they're
you know they're so uh aggressive in
some cases you go to Hong Kong Hong Kong
is actually opening up more now for
banking but why is Hong Kong
historically been so difficult to get a
bank account the banks literally don't
want more money they're so conservative
they have nowhere to put
it that's why wild that is absolutely
crazy what do you make of the uh of the
meme of the passport bro cuz you have
been doing this for significantly longer
than that Meme has come about but there
is a you know a strong Trend at the
moment of especially Western especially
men deciding that there is a problem
with the culture or the dating or the
government or whatever it is and then
going right yeah I'm I'm I'm out of here
is this were you an early adop of this
or is this sort of playing into your
guys's culture in some way what are you
what are you
seeing I don't I don't I'll be honest I
don't entirely know I my thought is that
that passport bro is kind of more
focused on The Dating element right I
that's kind of the a core driver of it
um you know I think for me many many
many years
ago um I mean I I I was an entrepreneur
I wanted to be an entrepreneur at 12
years old it wasn't cool back then like
now it's cool it wasn't cool when I
wanted to be an entrepreneur and so um
you know I wasn't the most popular guy
you just weird kid yeah just kind of
like who's this this the guy wants to
start a business well you're a freak uh
I remember like being 21 and my friends
would drag me to bars and girls would
like you know make fun of me because I
like I would go to like you know
business meetings and it was
embarrassing and retrospect like you
know going to these business meetings
but like like why are you wearing cuff
links like what are you a weirdo or
something and I remember being like 22
or 23 and I was on one of my early trips
and I met this girl girl from China and
she's like all the stuff that everyone
else thought was weird she's like
fascinated by like in Asia it's like
what is it like you're 23 and you've
like a business and you're making money
and like it's growing like that's pretty
like that's pretty like s like nobody in
China would be like under 50 would be
doing that like that's pretty cool and
it kind of showed me this kind of
Arbitrage opportunity um you know I mean
yeah I've you know dated people around
the world it's it's interesting I never
looked at it as something where you know
I've never want to be one of these guys
where it's like I'm going to places I
I've never chosen a place for dating
like koal and poor probably not a great
dating location um that's probably why
some of the people don't choose it um I
mean Thailand or Indonesia is probably
better so I've never really chosen a
place based on on dating um
but you know I I've enjoyed you know
meeting people from different places I I
you know I never wanted to make dating
kind of the only aspect but I certainly
think that um
people should seek competition in their
life I think the biggest thing I mean
you look for competition for a
restaurant you look for competition if
you're buying a product I mean people
use apps and how can I save $3 buying
this product somewhere else why don't
you use competition for your taxes and
for the government that serves you why
don't you use competition for the people
that you meet and again I mean really is
your whether you just want to find a
short-term relationship or whether
you're looking for your soulmate or
whatever you whatever it
is are the odds that they live around
you I mean really all the people out of
8 billion people the person that matches
you happen to also be born in Cleveland
Ohio like it seems ridiculous to me
right and and if you look back
throughout human history I mean people
didn't have so many options they just
learned to live with it but like you
lived in a village and there were 50
people and you just like chose one and
really those were the happiest
relationships those are the most
fulfilling
relationships
so I I mean I I I yeah I'm I'm you
know I'm not the guy remember we were
toing real estate in menine years ago
and people wanted to buy property for
Airbnb and we would go to some of the
buildings and they like oh this one the
government's for Airbnb but the building
banned
Airbnb and one one place we went they
told a story of some woman was coming
home with her child and a guy was uh
being uh serviced in the elevator like
they open the door opens and there's
this guy with with you know with the
woman and and it's like yeah we don't
want these people coming here anymore
obviously the idea that an american guy
goes to Colombia and wants to find
someone to to date I see nothing wrong
with that at all some people do I that's
ridiculous but obviously I don't I'd
like to you know I'd like to have a
certain level of class about it that
we're not doing things in
elers you know that's that's the the
optimal way to do it look Andrew I I
really I love your work I think it's a
very first principles approach to people
who live on a rock and these lines
around it are pretty arbitrarily drawn
apart from the oceans and even they they
weren't done of your own choosing and to
think about it from first principles I
really really like it I think your input
is is massively needed and and really
hugely uh like inspiring actually so I I
really I really love all of the stuff
that you're doing if someone wants to
get started uh with this if they said
right I'm bought in this sounds like
something that's kind of cool what are
the first places that they should
go we have a YouTube channel I think
over 2500 videos we put something out uh
you know 15 16 times a month with these
ideas you can watch and get the vibe um
our website we've got almost that many
articles Nomad capital.com if you want
it a bit more aggregated I wrote a book
called Nomad capitalist it's on Amazon
it's more storytelling than specific
ideas we talk about some of the ideas we
talk about what's not possible talk
about you know what you can do through
the lens of 15 years of my exploring
this so the book is a way to aggregate
it down into a shorter read uh and then
we Host this this annual event called
Nomad capist live and we bring a cur
rated list of people who everything from
Frontier Market investing to you know
giving birth overseas to lowering your
taxes we bring some of our staff that
talks about our client work so you know
from free to 10 bucks to Live Events and
then you'll do white glove service I'm
going to guess as well for the people
that need
it yeah if you have you know a mid six
fig income or a low seven fig net worth
or above we work with people all the way
up to you know billionaires to put
together these holistic strategies
because you heard me multiple times
throughout uh saying okay well this bank
account probably doesn't work on its own
but if you got a citizenship because you
opened it like you know you wna you want
to kind of consider the holistic nature
uh and you have to consider the holistic
nature given our our tax conversations I
mean nothing works in a vacuum you can't
just put your company in the British
Virgin Islands and not move and think
you're going to save tax because there's
all kinds of rules around how that works
and so you have to understand that and
so that's what we help people figure out
is is not only the known unknowns but
the unknown unknowns oh yeah Andrew I
appreciate you thank you for
today thank you if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe